hey it's me again in this video we're
going to show you an amazing technique
to help sinuses reduce honest stress so
just real quick my disclaimers we're not
training science infection or any type
of sinus disease this is just a great
technique to open up the sinuses so you
can breathe better and it has to do with
acupressure so here's how it works
in this is my great drawing of the side
of the head with someone looking this
way and we have seven bones in the neck
and you have different parts of the
nervous system that correlate with
different organs and glands it just so
happens the second vertebra in the neck
c2 cervical - connects to the sinus
passages up here so there's a direct
connection neurologically to the sinuses
okay so what you're going to be doing is
you're going to be using acupressure not
needles to press this way from back to
forward at the second vertebra okay so
I'm going to demonstrate this with my
camera person right now check it out so
in the back of the neck you can see that
we have the back of the skull right here
and then we come down to the first
vertebra and the second one third one
fourth fifth sixth seventh okay so what
we want to do is take your there's two
ways to do it you can have someone do it
on you and I'm going to show you how to
do that you take your middle finger
right here and your thumb and we place
it right underneath the skull and we
drop down one inch okay and you should
be on the second vertebra and then we
just press in like this so we're
pressing directly in at the second
vertebra and you're going to feel a kind
of a knot if they have sinus problems
this is going to be hard as a rock and
so we take our other hand and we we stay
in it hold the head the forehead try not
to mess up their hair that's the most
important part and we just press like
this like a scissors at this second bone
and we just hold pressure lightly for
two minutes they're going to start
breathing better it's going to open up
the sinuses right here now if you don't
have someone to do this on
you you can use a massage tool like this
depending on the sides of the neck you
can take this and press it right in now
in him I'm going to take the medium
width and press right in here but you
could actually see this is a tripod this
can go back on a couch or a tall back
chair or laying on his back so we press
this right down here and we just hold
this pressure so we don't use to have to
have someone do it on us we press right
through in here and then he lays there
and he just lets the gravity put
pressure on these points and that will
open up the sinuses again this is great
for sleep apnea just sign of stuff so
it's a second it's not right up
underneath the skull it's down a little
bit like an inch down and we press
directly inward like that okay so that's
the procedure of how you'd use
acupressure again you can use it on your
fingers right here come straight in or
you can use that device so there's two
more quick things you can do for the
sinus stress number one we can drop the
pH now what does it mean drop the pH it
means that in in your body you have
different levels of acidic things or
alkaline things and the higher goes the
more alkaline higher goes above seventh
so in the blood your body balances the
pH between seven point three six and
seven point four four that's a very
narrow range so the blood is slightly
alkaline alright and in other parts of
the body that's our that are more acid
but so we want it within this range but
what happens when the pH goes a little
too too much above this when it goes
above seven point four four and becomes
too alkaline you start to getting more
allergies more arthritis more histamines
those are the things that create Jing
and things like that so one great
technique you can do is just to drop the
pH a little bit by giving someone
something more acidic like apple cider
vinegar so if you have allergies
something to reduce it all you have to
do is add a little apple cider vinegar
to your
like a teaspoon or actually and some
lemon juice so a teaspoon of lemon juice
a teaspoon of apple cider vinegar to
your water and start drinking that that
drops a pH a little bit and brings it
within this range and so we're just
talking about relative values we're not
talking about making your blood very
very ass or anything like that we just
want to drop it down so it's within the
range so it's not excessively alkaline
all right so we want to drink that that
will help reduce allergies when you go
up too high and you start taking things
that are too alkaline
it can aggravate the allergies all right
so we want to upset a vinegar lemon and
water to help drop the pH a little bit
and help your sinuses alright number two
a vitamin a now what does vitamin A do
it supports the mucous membranes it
supports the inner skin of the sinuses
the respiratory the entire track all the
way down all the skin internally and
externally as well so vitamin A will
help support the tissues of the sinuses
to help reduce the inflammation in the
sinuses and guess what has the most
vitamin A in addition to carrots it
would be kale all right so again that
kale shake keeps coming back to kale you
take that every morning and helps your
breathing it helps your sleeping and
it's great for sleep apnea because sleep
apnea is really a congested sinus and
you want to reduce the mucous membrane
swelling and kale is one way to do it so
go ahead and apply these three things
acupressure dropping your pH and vitamin
A